okay our second speaker this morning is
Jones allenstein with the second part of
solving polom equation thank you y uh so
today's uh uh talk uh we'll talk about
isolated Solutions first how do we use
homotopies to compute isolated Solutions
uh what's sort of the geometry behind
positive dimensional solution sets and
how can we do computations on them and
then at the end I'll talk about the
complexity of the of the solving
approach is and how it relates to male
problem uh so if you recall the we're
going to take a polinomial system
F and let's assume that it's a square
system so the number of variables is
equal
to the number of polinomial that we have
the nice thing about Square systems is
that is sort of well conditioned I can
perturb the coefficients and my
Solutions uh will still exist and the
idea is to set up a
Hopi plus T * G of
X you give me f my goal is to construct
G appropriately and now trace the
solution curves so we want to set up
this
and then
Trace solution
curves defined by H equal Z the nice
thing about this is each solution curve
can be tracked independently so we have
a good parallelization of this solving
approach okay so the first thing we want
to do is how do we set up G and uh
there's different approaches and let's
start with the most basic choice for
setting up be and this is what's called
a bazo
homity so bzo here corresponds to bazo's
theorem and it'll be generically sharp
with respect to bazo's theem so assume
that di is the degree of fi and now I'm
just going to take my
homotopy to be very
simply 1 - t plus T * the following
system x to the D1 -1 X1 to the D1 -1 xn
the DN
-1 so my G of X is this very nice simple
system
here what do we know about G of
x
hopefully we can all write down the
solutions to it it should be clear so G
ofx equal
to0 as D1 * n * DN
Solutions they're all non-
singular everything is nice about
G what's the problem as I originally
have it formulated suppose F has
coefficients which are real this system
has coefficients which are real the real
numbers cause some issues so we want to
take advantage of the uh algebraic
closure of the complex numbers and add
in some uh complex uh number here where
gamma is a complex number we have to
move away from the reals to the
algebraically uh their closure the
complex numbers good
and so now we can prove a
theorem that uh for all but finitely
many sorry why do you need the
GMA so if we don't have the gamma there
think about
uh think about uh F here having uh let's
say X2 + 1 is our F and now we want to
deform from x^2 -
1 * 1 - t plus T *
this this has real Roots this has
complex Roots the only way to get from
real roots to complex Roots is to pass
through a
singularity and uh oh oh I see you want
to avoid similarities on your path
exactly very
good
okay and as you will see here that's one
of my uh statements of the theorem so
for all but finitely many uh points on
the unit circle and complex numbers the
following things holds
one
uh there are D1 through
DN
continuous solution paths
let's say
x such
that all right uh let's move to the
other side of the
board what would be nice properties of
this well the first thing we would like
is they should satisfy our
equation so for all T in
the interval between 0 and
one the other thing that would be
nice is if they were
smooth so this example that I wrote up
here for uh JM I believe had a
singularity at tal to 12 that I've now
erased so we would like these to be
smooth so that the condition number is
finite along the path and so we can
nicely Trace along them however we have
no control over what happens at t equal
to Zer at F so the only thing we can say
this is this is for the open
interval open on the left side at tal Z
we have no control over F you gave me f
i don't know what the solution I picked
G so that at least away from zero
everything is nice
and
good what else would we
like the next thing that we would like
is to look at the set of end
points that's that x sub t a solution
path and the limit as T goes to
zero actually
exist okay so maybe it's helpful to draw
a
picture this picture is morally correct
but not mathematically
correct so here's my
T and here's my X space
over here at tal to 1 I have the roots
of unity if they're appropriate uh
choices and then over here I don't know
what I have I have some points I have
some
curves I don't know what what I have and
now I have these nice smooth continuous
paths which sort of I don't know come
over like this and maybe some go
off and diverge to a so this is theem
morally correct statement so if I look
at the set of end points the limit
points which converge in my aine
space What Would We like to be true we
would like to be
true remember this is the isolated
points the isolated
Solutions we would like like this to be
true and indeed it actually is true so
the set of end points contains all of
the isolated Solutions and obviously
every end point is also a solution as
this uh something stronger than this is
actually
true and uh in
fact e contains
a
point on every
connected component not algebraic
component but connected
components exactly so it's not
irreducible but it's the connected
components in the ukian uh ukan topology
over the complex
numbers so here I drew a sort of a some
kind of connected piece I'm going to at
least find one point on that connected
set so if there's an embedded component
you won't necessarily find it exactly so
as we talked about
yesterday if I have X2 and
XY I'm guaranteed to find a point on the
line x equal to zero but I may or may
not find the embedded point and if you
have two intersecting lines all you're
guaranteed is you'll hit one point on
one of the two lines exactly only one
maybe one maybe more I don't know it all
depends upon sort of uh your choice on
on the start system where it ends
up okay what happens if the system has
no solution ah then all paths go to
Infinity so if this system had no
Solutions let's say X and X Y
-1 all the paths will go to
Infinity what else would we like to be
true suppose xcar is
indeed isolated an isolated
solution how many paths would we like to
converge to
xar the number of paths
uh let's call it
ending at
xar is exactly the
multiplicity of your
system so if you have a multiplicity two
root for
example let's say I want to solve
X2
and I start with x^2 minus 1 here I
don't need a gamma gamma well gamma is
equal to one works here you can rewrite
this as x^2 minus t and now you can
simply draw the picture at tal to
1 I have one and minus one and both of
these converge to the
origin
so X2 has a multiplicity two root I have
exactly two paths converging to
it okay so that's the end of the
statement of the theorem and it's
true and people have brought up many
concerns and so let me address some of
those
if my system has no Solutions then all
of my paths will diverge to Infinity how
do I track a path that has infinite
length my computer cannot do this I'll
be long dead before my computer ever
reaches Infinity so how do I do this
well I transform my path into a compact
path by going to projective space
so
compactify to
yield finite length
path so there was a homework problem
that uh I'll talk about sort of to
demonstrate
we have 2X y + 3x + 4 y -
1 and then y^2 + 5x + 2 y -
3 and we correctly found out last night
at the homework session that this has
exactly three real
RS okay so now I set up my home
XY T is f of
XY * 1 - t + gam * T * x^ -1 y^ 2
- and so the
picture if you think of XY and C2 in
this direction and T between 0 and one
over here I have four points over here I
have three points
I know that three of the four paths have
to converge smoothly to those three
points and then the other one has to
diverge to
Infinity so now let's compactify this so
we want to go from
C2 and embed that into
P2 and see that we can turn this
infinite length path into a
finite
all right so now let's say that x y and
z are my coordinates in
P2 3x C + 4 y c - c^
2 Y 2 + 5x C + 2 y c - 3 c^ 2
1 - t + * T x^2 - c^ 2 y^ 2
- since this is a compact space all four
of my paths have to be Compact and so
the
picture looks exactly like this here's
the T here's the XY
Z and can any tell me what the point at
Infinity
is
yes it's the0 1
z0 and so in the aine case I was
diverging to Infinity in this direction
and so all I've done is I've
compactified it so now I explicitly see
the end point is exactly the direction
as I go to
Infinity okay good
so you avoid infinite length paths by
compactifying things and different
compactifications lead to
uh different types of
homotopies as we will see shortly why
did I compactify C2 into
P2 maybe I want to do c Cross C and
compactify this into P1 cross
P1 and that exactly is a two homogeneous
BAS the which we'll talk about very
shortly okay so the choice of
compactification will impact how how
well or efficient your method is for
solving
good what are some other
issues singular end
points oh yes a priori you well here you
you can say that because there are low
degree and there is some arithmetic
obstruction but a prior you don't know
that that at that goes to Infinity goes
at an isolated point right a priori I do
not know but plug in Z equal to zero and
you see that here here we can but we
have PA that go to Infinity they can go
to some uh positive dimensional
component that exactly and my theorem
still holds if I switch from aine space
to projective space I get a point on
every connected component at it or every
connected component over the projector
space and so if it lies at Infinity I
get a point on
it okay so in this one all four of the
end points in projective space were nice
isolated non- singular points so I can
use Newton's method to quadratically
converge uh hopefully it was
demonstrated in the homeworks the power
of Newton's method quadratic convergence
is very powerful singular
endpoints don't know what's going to
happen I could diverge I could linearly
converge I don't know so how do we
handle singular inls so how to
compute compute the end
point when the
Jacobian is
rank
all
right and the
idea is to stay far
away from the ill
Condition it's only singular exactly at
t equal to zero so if my T is positive
I'm in a nice well- conditioned region
except in the middle
so here's my T and now I'm thinking of t
as a complex number at t equal to
zero I have a rank deficient
Jacobian everywhere
else my Jacobian is full rank so can I
use things in this well condition region
to approximate a ill condition
answer
has anyone seen things like this
before project in the space to
be yeah so one way you can do is you can
just track your path close and then sort
of project in some direction
and what you
know what you know is that X of T has a
piso series expansion
uh close enough I think there's an a
somewhere in there
maybe that's close enough the
Au e Au has a series expansion we start
series
expansion in a
ball
containing tal Z and of course this is
an open ball as I've demonstrated here
so x sub T in this ball has a piso
series expansion and that t equal to Z
is where I want to find it so I can do
exactly uh what you suggested sort of uh
so one
option is the pick
points uh in this
ball so IE
compute X of t I for
various
I fit up we SE
series SE
series and then
evaluate at t
z
good assuming an isolated point no no
no the nice thing is is it's isolated
with respect to the homotopy x of T away
from zero but at t equal to Z I don't
know what happens it could be it could
be isolated it could be positive
function nonetheless I have a quisto
series
expansion
there
so let's think back to uh the very
simple homotopia I wrote down
before x^2 -
t One
path was on the positive square root and
the other path was on the minus square
root and for those that don't know what
quiso series are these are fractional
laurant series with a constant
denominator so here I have a an actual
power Series in t to
the2
good so in
general X of T and let's switch a
marker in general x sub T looks like
this
summation for uh J = to K to
Infinity of a subj * T J C where
K is some integer it could be
negative and
C is a positive
integer has a name and this is what's
called the winding
number so the winding number is a
complex analytic
uh uh number which says that if I do
loops around this this is the number of
times I have to wind around before I
come back to where I started so this
should
suggest something about koshy's integral
form
so either we have a quiso series and we
try and approximate it or we could just
go the rout of using uh complex
numbers and do Co
integral
integral so this says that X Sub 0 is 1
over 2 pi C interal integral from 0 to 2
pi c x subr e i Theta D
Theta
for 0 to 2 pi I 2 pi C of 2 pi C IA yes
yeah good yeah sorry 2 pi C and for I
know this is true because it's on a
small ball so if my radius is
sufficiently small I get this
okay so that's uh one way to approximate
uh singular end
points and uh just so you know these go
by the name of end
games what happens at the end of my
path okay after I've approximated these
yes go ahead how do you find the winding
number we
before ah so one way to find the winding
number is to actually do what I said do
loops around it until you come back to
where you
started the other way is just to think
okay this winding number is going to be
some uh positive integer so I'm going to
test that c 1 and Cal 2 and Cal 3 and
try and approximate it if you have
enough point points you can make a very
good educated guess on what it
is it's a difficult question one way you
actually compute it by integrating
around the curve the other way is you
just
guess
okay uh even if we can approximate our
end point accurately we would like
Newton's method Newton's method the
power of quadratic convergence there so
so how to
restore quadratic
convergence of
new so the idea is my Jacobian is rank
deficient there's extra conditions that
are going wrong there so if I add
in extra
conditions to my
system to
remove the
singularity
so let me give you an example and I hope
everyone has seen this before univariate
pols of Multiplicity M what do you know
about a univariate polinomial of
Multiplicity
M so in the Univar
case suppose that F of xar equal to zero
and the multiplicity of F at
xar is
n can I construct a new
system such that xar has multiplicity
one hopefully you've seen this before
but I'm going to add a Twist to
it of course you know that the M minus
first
derivative it satisfies the M minus
first derivative and it's not singular
but I'm going to add a Twist to it and
just keep all of the other
derivatives start with the system I have
add the first derivative did that make
it non- singular no add the second
derivative did that make it non-
singular no keep going until I've added
the M minus first and now it's non
singular so now I know that g of
xar is equal to zero and and the
multiplicity of g at
xar the deflation methods um I'm a
little confused with the order of
events so so you're doing the method it
doesn't converge yes so then what so
then you just
start then you throw in all the first
derivatives and if it still doesn't
converge quadratically you throw in all
the second derivatives is is that what
you're doing exactly but you add in rank
conditions on the so in the Univar case
you just there's just one derivative add
it but in the multivariant case there's
directional derivatives to add it so in
this direction this derivative vanishes
so I need to add that into my system but
how do you know how do you that's okay
good so that's exactly my question how
do you know which ones so so all you
know is that Newton's method is not
converging exactly so how do you know
which derivative to which so I go back
to my methods to approximate my solution
better MH I know this will work but I
can't integrate things I can only
numerically integrate them so now I use
a higher order numerical integrator
compute this more accurately and now
plug it back into my system find the
find the derivatives which vanish add
those in did it work no come back
compute more efficient more how do you s
the directions how do you select the
that's that's the question okay so let
me tell you the easiest way also destroy
that it was
square of course my system here is not
going to be square anymore it's going to
be over determined I'm not worried about
that I just don't know how you okay so
here's the the the easiest way to say
this okay and so this was FM paper by
myself and Charles moner take F and say
you have a good approx o imation to xar
so this is approximately zero now
compute the
rank of the
Jacobian so if I have a good
approximation I can use SPD to computers
and so let's say this is R so now I'm
going to take my
system and I'm going to add in all the r
+ one by R +1
minors of my
Jacobi
that's a lot that's a
lot but the nice thing is is that you
don't need all of them you only need the
co-dimension many of
them on the
average uh for explicit computation you
can pick which ones you need at your
point you're interested
in this is how you avoid picking a
direction yes I see yes and now you
iterate this is my new system compute
the rank of the the fact that these are
very high degree doesn't bother your
computer uh what bothers my computer is
the fact that there's a lot of
them more than that the degree is R
times the degree exactly because all I'm
doing is local computation there I can
efficiently evaluate each one of these
minors and their
derivatives I don't need to expand them
out so when you go to second and third
and fourth derivatives do do tensors get
actually used in tensor methods uh not
right now but it could be you could
structur structure so yes absolutely so
is that clear things up I'm fine okay
the fact that this is overdetermined
doesn't cause any problems no because uh
there's a
subsystem which is full Rank and that's
all I need is a full rank sub system
you just take a generic substance
exactly and we don't care that doing
this we throw away all the other
Solutions now only there I'm only
interested in this particular solution
for your other Solutions you might have
to do something completely different
your multiplicity may be different it
doesn't matter but for this particular
solution how do I restore quadratic
convergence of Newton's method for this
for the Newton iteration now the
derivatives is it's not a quadratic
quadratic anymore you take
thise no you take a random subsystem of
this which is the next uh oh okay the
next thing okay I wonder how would the
iteration be this
one so you could either take a pseudo
inverse of this of this or you could
take a random subsystem and then use
that okay for your newon method and you
get quadratic convergy in both of them
okay and then if you take a r sub the
multiplicity will be y that's exactly my
next statement
here so singular things naturally lead
to overdetermined conditions because
there's extra extra miners that banish
so there's extra conditions that manage
there how to handle overdetermined
systems okay so start with your
polinomial
G your system G1 through
GN and X is X1 through xn and now look
at this
system a
* G of
X where a is a n by n
Matrix so now my f is a square system so
I can do all computations with f whereas
G is an over
deter all
right and so now we're to bertini's
Theory how do the solutions of f and g
relate and in particular to Peter's
question what about the
multiplicity so this is bertini's
theorem
so there is a
zisy open
dense
subset of the N byn minor uh n byn
matrices let's call it
U such that for all matrices a and
u
what's the relationship between f and
g obviously if I have a solution of g a
* 0 is still zero so I know that
this contains everything that I started
with what about the extra stuff
what happens to the extra stuff it
satisfies a randomization but doesn't
actually satisfy my system
consists of finitely
many non-
singular and I have to tell you what
it's with respect to non- singular with
respect to F Solutions
points
Solutions but I thought you would expect
other
than since this is
so oh I see
sorry okay so my system my randomiz
system contains everything I had before
plus some non- singular points that are
sort of
somewhere lying out there the more
important thing is what happens to the
multiplicity suppose I have a isolated
solution of
G then the
multiplicity uh if x is in here then the
multiplicity of
f is greater than or equal to the
multiplicity
of
G with
equality if
either is
one so if my multiplicity of my
overdetermined system is one then the
multiplicity of my random sum system
will also be
one so if either of these are one then
you know the other one has to be one or
or the
multiplicity of f ofx star isal two if
this multiplicity is two this one also
has to be
two okay let's look at an
example why do they have to be equal if
they're
two if the multiplicity is two then it's
singular and therefore it's singular
with respect to G cuz cuz that can't be
one and singular things can't have
multiplicity one so well why can't it be
I
mean it can't be higher
equality because if you think of
Multiplicity f is greater than yeah yeah
F
contains stuff G I got it sorry little
dyslexic to I like every
day
so let's look at this system F2 XY
y^2 just a know complicity of F and X
star is larger than two then we don't
know we don't know and this example will
demonstrate okay what is the
multiplicity of g at the
origin three very good 1 X and Y are the
uh standard monomial and there's three
of those take a random sub
system uh I'm going to use notation like
this well let's just stick with the
standard
notation and here a lies on my zisy open
Den
subset what is now the
multiplicity of F at the
origin four
so my multiplicity is four and that
obviously is upper bound on three but
not
equal now comes a a user based question
for those that have used beri the
software which answer does patini give
you three or
four it's probably going to take
advantage of the structure and give you
three but I but I've never used it
gives you four PR gives you four because
that is exactly equal to the number of
paths which
converge this because this is a square
system this equals the number of
paths and that's what for the software
counts how many paths converge and so
that's that's what B the software will
give you so that's just the quick aside
that if you have overdetermined systems
make sure you understand the software
actually is
Computing
okay
questions
concerns so is there an issue in picking
the a maybe you might like to be
interested in picking a somewhat sparse
a still in some other sense generic
enough what about so the art of picking
a so you can take for instance this
reorder your G's so that you like the
ones at the top and you don't care about
the ones at the bottom now you can sort
of randomize the ones at the bottom up
to the top and here the same theorem
holds on as risky open subset of the
choice of matrices B that's simply
because it only matters about the row
space of a exactly just taking the shg
off exactly so you can add in structured
onto your Ace you don't have to be
completely dense uh uh completely dense
m
you can add in lots of structure well
I'm also thinking about pushing the
number of paths down maybe if I locally
you know think about some polygons or
something like that
uh
right we'll leave it at
that okay so now let's return to
Steiner's uh
problem so the question is who rememb
Steiner's problem from two days
ago a couple people okay so it was
count the number of
conics a
tangent to five
given General
conics thank you
3264 very
good I'll get to that okay and remember
if I pick one conic I have a
hypersurface of conics tangent to that
and the degree of that hypersurface is
six so this translates into a
system of five
pols here x is in P5 and you can think
of conx as equivalent to P5 and the
degree of fi is 6 so this is a square
system and so now you track 6 to the 5th
which is
7,776
paths what happens to those
paths I know I'm going to get the
isolated
Solutions because my space is compact
all of the other ones have to converge
and therefore they have to converge to
the line to the double lines so if I can
do arithmetic in my
head lie on the so-called a double
Lin uh maybe I should just say is a
double
line so these are honest conics tangent
and these are are double lines which are
fakely tangent because you have the
multiplicity coming from the
double so Steiner in 18 roughly 1860 had
access to Modern 18 1848 48 had access
to Modern computers uh you can do this
computation relatively fast and see that
the answer is not
7,776 but indeed
326 this also proves that there are no
other connected components the only
connected components in this system are
exactly the double
lines
okay so that's a nice application of of
uh bzu
homotopy so they are all in the same
component all these 45 yes but this you
then you see it if you I mean if you
compute it right you actually see that
this one of these each of these conics
is a
double right it it it can Factor as a
linear
Square okay so now uh Baron sort of gave
a hint that maybe you want to do some
extra structure on here Basu
homotopies usually are not what you want
to try they overestimate the number of
solutions very often so
typically
systems have a rich
structure and by that the system have
and so you want to exploit that
structure in your
homop if you think back to my uh I'm
it's not exactly the same one but close
enough uh y^ 2 + 2x + 3 y - 2
doesn't
matter this wasn't the intersection of
two quadrics it really was the
intersection of a curve of degree 1 one
and a curve of degree one2 there's
really three solutions there on C Cross
C so now I should be able to construct a
start
system gamma which has that same
structure so this is linear in X and Y
so pick your favorite
linear in x y x - * y - one this is
linear in X so pick your favorite linear
in X and then quadratic in
y and so there you
go these both
have have the same two homogeneous
structure and therefore my theorem at
the beginning of the lecture holds for
almost uh for all the finitely many
choices of gamma you get exactly what
the rest of the theor
say and now hopefully you see how to
count if I take xal to 1 X is not two
therefore one of these two take a cub
one
there side but it's it's it's the so the
degree of this is 1 one and the degree
of
this is uh 1
two and so I need one linear in X and
two linear in
y so even though it's not cubic as you
would think of cubics It Is by degree
one two and therefore I need a
polinomial by degree one
two okay so this is a multihomogeneous
what are some other structures that you
wouldd like to
exploit
polytopes I want to exploit the monomial
structure of this system so now instead
of this this start system I create a new
system and I'll explain the notation in
a
second so I'm going to replace this
system here with this system and each
one of these boxes means pick your
favorite random
number so I've taken my given system and
thrown away your coefficients I don't
like your coefficients I'm going to
substitute my own
coeffs and I'm going to generate them
from my favorite random
distribution solve this system and then
track the homotopia paths over to
here
good and
so Baron can tell
you uh much more details about this than
I
can how many how many points do you have
to have over here so the number of
paths is equal to the BKK
Bound for your system so the mixed
volume of the corresponding Newton
polytop so you can use the combinatorics
to compute this bound and then use the
polyhedral nature of this to compute
this Solutions and then deform from
there okay uh where we going on
time what if you have sort of
determinantal type equations do you have
a special thing for
those so the art of homotopia
construction is knowing how you
constructed your system so then you can
construct a a good start system so
typically anything that you can find a
well anything which is a constructive
bound on the number of isolated
Solutions so if you have a constructive
way to bound a number of solutions
typically you can turn that into a
homotopia so for determinantal things
there is a constructive way to uh to to
bound a number of things and so if there
are problems of Interest generate the
family of those though generically that
will have that bound and then therefore
you can set up the problem is solving
one instance yes so there's two problems
one is counting the bound so how do you
how do you actually compute this Bound
for instance and then the other thing is
how do you actually find the right
number of solutions to the system that
agrees with this and then you can do uh
the
H so this is this is the art and
systems that many of you generate have
lots of
structure and the art is finding that
structure and being able to exploit it
there's a lot of room for generating
special types of hopes for your system
to
Vis how's the randomness helping you the
randomness is helping me here that this
will have all um all of these Solutions
because I have the constant term here I
know this is true all of these Solutions
will be non- singular and isolated and
so therefore my my home path will be
smooth except at the very end possibly
so the randomness is guaranteeing me
this um uh non singular Solutions at the
at this system it's guaranteeing also
that this system is well ped yes yes so
this is another important issue in
numerical analysis absolutely with high
probability of course are guarantees not
like uh
unconditional
right with probability one b based upon
your reasonable choice of random numbers
it seems like the the new system that we
created is harder potentially to Sol
than the one that you started with and
Frank pointed this out that's the AR so
what did bar do here he deformed to sort
of binomial systems binomials are much
easier to solve and then lifted back to
Solutions here so that is also the art
how do I solve this
system well you might as well just
deform your original system then but
this could have singular Solutions this
could have positive dimensional
components at least I'm deforming to a
solution that I know is
nice so what if you pick let's say your
four favorite points and then so that
you know the solutions of the other
system and then choose your coefficients
which vanish at those
absolutely that's right why why did I
pick easiest way why did I pick this one
why can I pick so uh A1 B1 b i for IAL 1
to 4 and then find the two pols that
vanish at exactly these four points
they're equivalent so absolutely yeah
well it's actually extremely easy to
find given a solution to find a system
of the structure you want that that has
that as a solution absolutely and that's
that's also a method that people are
thinking about yes so my favorite
homotopies right now are Newton
homotopies
pick your favorite Y and at tal to 1 I
have a
solution and now I can deform from y
along my curve so it's very easy uh to
write down a homotopy pick y write down
a homotopy that vanishes there uh you
can also do what are called Fix point
homotopies
and I don't understand I don't
understanding f xus t y y is a y is a
fixed
point I pick Yar first oh and then I
construct this
homop and when T is equal to 1 and x
equal to Y star I have a
solution you can also
do+ T * x -
Yar and again when T is equal to one y
star is a solution of this and now I can
track that
path I don't have in this case at tal 1
there is a unique solution but in this
case there could be multiple solutions
that I don't know what they are a priori
I'd have to
confute good so let's a a different
Penh just a question about your nure yes
why is that
called this has been asked several times
by several
referees
on the same paper uh different
papers and the reason is uh the best
answer I can give you is there are some
classical papers in engineering that
call these newon
homotopies and therefore I'm sticking
with their
name that's the best answer I can give
you call it Einstein
Rosen uh from
time uh from roughly the 60s from the
60s
yes so that's the that's the best answer
I've given the referees whove
asked and the fix Point uh that's a
similar uh similar thing uh these have
been used for 40 or 50 years and they
just sort of got the
name
afterwards okay uh I shouldn't have
erased this five uh
all of these homotopies that I've
written up are all in a general class
called coefficient parameter
H and the idea is if I can solve for a
sufficiently general point
then I can change either my coefficients
or some other parameters and solve at
the system that I want so here my uh Coe
my parameter space is the set of all B
variant polinomial systems where the
first polinomial has degree 1 one and
the second polinomial has degree 1 two
so this is really a homotopy inside of
that space the same thing with this this
is a homotopy in the set of polinomial
with the same mon struction and you can
sort of uh generalize this so if I look
at Steiner's problem suppose I
solve solve
Steiner for my conic C1 through
C5 I know there's 32 64 Solutions and
now suppose I want to
solve for new conic C1 Prime through C5
Prime I can deform in the space of
conics from the solutions to this to the
solutions to this and I only need to
track the right number of of paths so
here I'm going to have a generically
sharp homotopy that consists of
3264 uh is that the right number yes
okay so why do you know you're not going
to have to pass through a double line ah
very good uh you're going to take a
general path in your parameter space and
the only way you can end up at at a
singular Point as if your conics were to
gener so with probability one uh the
path between these two will
singular but now this feature is a
little different from the previous one
the sense that it's no longer linear T
is not the six exactly so here I really
have a nonlinear parameter space that
I'm moving through over here I have a
linear parameter space the linear aine
space given by these eight coefficients
why are those nonlinear because it's a
discriminant so for two Conex to be
tangent is 66 oh oh right right it's a
it's a
36 yes thank you okay so everything you
would like uh to hold for linear SPAC is
also holds for irreducible primam Stace
and as long as you can stay inside your
irreducible family all the theorems I've
said have uh will hold with the with
proper
respect
good should we get time for a discussion
uh what time did I start quarter quter
okay I still have plenty of time you're
ending
in oh
sorry
okay uh let me end with
this my apologies I was
hopeing at least let me State smil 17th
problem so the idea is I want a
deterministic uh
procedure for
computing a
root of a
system in Pol
time on the
AC okay what does it mean to compute a
root it means to compute a point in the
quadratic Convergence Zone of Newton's
method
okay and uh uh if you replace
deterministic here with
uniform uh
probabilistic probalistic this has been
solved by
belon
and part
of and if you keep deterministic I
believe the best is and to the log log
n where n here is the input
size and this is
by berer please forgive me as I misspell
your name but he could probably tell you
the correct
correction it's an i if you're write it
messy enough you can't tell where
okay I'm done thank
you
questions uh what you can think of this
is the number of steps my path tracker
has to take is polinomial in the in the
input
SP what do it me what the average pick
your
favorite uh probability on the set of
pols uh with a fixed
degree there is a fixed uh probability
is SM favor probability okay but the
original statement of the problem did
not say use this probability
space but uh pick your favorite or sm's
favorite uh probability space on the on
the polinomial system and then on the
average you can track this path in
polinomial
time so uh going back maybe rewind 15
minutes when people were talking about
the the polytop homotopia and so on if I
give you a arithmetic circuit or I draw
the circuit for instance that computes a
given polinomial can you then design a
better homotopy knowing that's the way
I'm going to evaluate my
polinomial in theory you would like
to how did to do it in practice I think
will be problem
dependent we also also a number of
solutions understandable from from the
circuit yeah I
mean I mean just have in mind I have a
lot of my favorite types of polinomial
that I never write them down exactly but
I know how to evaluate them and I can
tell you how to evaluate them and it
sounded like what you said is if if I
have a method to tell you how to
evaluate a polinomial then you can
design a homop to the help what you have
to do is have a method which you can
solve a polinomial in sort of the same
class of those
pols assuming if I tell you a root of
that polinomial in addition to telling
you how to evaluate no no the structure
of that Pol system uh if um if you have
a program to evaluate the polom your
program um Works in a certain number of
steps each steps comput a new variable
an intermediate variable from the
previous ones that's an one equation so
uh you have an implicit polytop or
program so this can be used those will
be um polytop with uh maybe even three
points
each uh it's not clear if this will be
easy to compute mixed volumes but it is
possible in
principle yes so suppose I have a pic
chip or Black Fox that can do pic
arithmetic really really really really
well yes would you would you use it
what's the first thing you would do with
it I would try and design a a
unbreakable
code in this context ah good where where
do you see a potential for ptic methods
rather than you know numerical
so what you're trying to do here is
you're trying to
uh is you're trying to set up a system
of
equations so as I write this system down
I haven't implicitly told you where my
x's or T's come from this really is a
system of equations and you pick your
favorite field that you want to do the
computation for uh if you think in terms
of the homotopies then I have to have
some kind of continuity properties to be
able to uh to track my system but this
is really just a system of equations
that uh hopefully defin some curves and
if I can do ptic arithmetic on you're
doing a dynamic you're running a
dynamical system absolutely so if I can
do ptic Dynamics exactly so if you want
to
you know x uh sub one is a solution of
here and then my Dynamics uh says that
my
Jacobian this
inverse
anyway so if you use the Dynamics you
have to have continuity of T So T here
has to be continuous and then you can
sort of uh use nice kind of lifting
methods to uh to approximate and lift
but by the way there is a master CES by
pal Bing well he transfer some of these
things in this SM problem context to the
P but locally everything is very nice
even nice the complex numers but there
is a global problem because this is
totally
discontinous this
idea breaks down so
absolutely the purp notification yes can
talk
about any other questions sorry for
going over
time
experiment sorry do you actually them
yes sorry the people that know me are
laugh don't run into issues like I mean
you know chotic F oh it depends on he's
asking about chaotic FS yeah it dep
depends on how you set things up and uh
so I've done experiments you know in the
general case and there everything is
nice but then also for particular
systems you have what's the best
homotopy how do these paths behave if
things go off to Infinity uh do they
come close together so uh conditioning
conditioning is a major problem so if I
have paths that come close together how
do I correctly track between these two
things how do I design homotopy so my
paths are far apart so that I don't have
ill conditioning nearby these are lots
of experiments that I and others have
run and the nice thing is is that well
you can design homotopies which come
close together you have to use higher
Precision to be able to see that they're
separate and design algorithms to be
able to handle these
things yes but once you adapt the
Precision are you provably able to say
that you have a correct answer because
you have used the correct PR uh so I'm
going to I believe it was a recent paper
by you and Mike
Shu uh to do a provably adapt uh the
Precision ad prision so what's
currently he doesn't even know what
okay so implemented in in my software
bertini is a heuristic adaptation of the
Precision uh yeah there are new
certifiable ways
to let I answer uh like this you fix a
Precision you can do the calculations
and prove you have an approximate
Ro uh if you have an an
and is
generate uh you need a certain Precision
to get to that point and that Precision
is estimated and well understood it
depends on the condition number at
that so so the route is well posed no
problem well poed in the sense that it's
a
exactly non singular no it's a non the
exact route is non singular with respect
the condition number is something
related to the norm of the inverse of
the
derivative there are few corruption ter
but it's essentially that so in
principle it's possible to do numerical
algeb geometry in a way that your
answers are pro provably I mean your
answers are pro by you're running when
you're run the program you have a if
your end points are non singular if your
end points are non singular in the sense
that
they can still uh they they can't
converge so you have to start with the
correct number
of in the sense that if I have a generic
a sharp hopy where the number of star
points is equal to the number of end
points I can provably guarantee that I
have all of the solutions here they're
all distinct everything if if the pets
do
merge then you how do you so the notion
of approximate root means I'm in the
quadratic Convergence Zone of Newton's
method so if it's a singular Point what
does the quadratic convergence here mean
you have to come up with a new
definition of how do I approximate this
rout do I give you a a deflation type
algorithm where I remove the
multiplicity and now prove that that was
the right way to remove the multiplicity
here I so what I guess what I'm trying
to understand is looking at the size of
the coefficients and the degree of
everything um is is there a an
abstraction to doing the cl gey to
prove the obstruction is uh the root
separation
bounds are whatever they are
exponentially dou exponential that that
is the
what is
your is your input real on complex
numbers or
coefficients
well that makes a difference because
with real and complex numbers you have a
surface of imposed system if you have
integers in principle uh if it is not
the generate the condition number will
be uh smaller than a certain bound and
if it is the well you can still do
culations okay I suggest that we
continue the discussion over
Lun so um especially for computer
scientists interested in rication stuff
like that there'll be some very basic
geometry
5 yeah thank
you
CR on the
are be able to do